اعلنا مالك وشريكه تيفاجنا ريف جيني
بدويجن ناقوته سيطره على كامل مدينه
سوليدار في مقاطعه دونيت الشرقيه اوكرانيا
وقال بريكودجين في حسابه على تيليجرام انه
وحده بجنر سيطرت على كامل الاراضي سوري
دار وين القتال لا يزال مستمرا في وسط
المدينه مع بعض القوات الاوكرانيه
المحاصره من جهته قالت السلطات المواليه
لروسيا في دونيتسكنا تحريرها سوليدار
يفتحوا الطريقه لتحرير اراضيها بشكل كامل
من جهتها قالت نائبته وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني ان الجيش الاوكرانيه لا يزال
يدافع عن مواقع في سوريا مؤكده ان الجيش
الروسيه يواصل القتال رغم الخسائر الضخمه
ونشرت وسائل الاعلاميه الروسيه صوره قالت
انها لملك شركه ايفا غناريف جيني بريكوجين
برفقه مقاتلين داخل احد انفاق المناجم في
مدينه سوليدار من جانبها ذكرت وكاله ريان
نوفوتي ان الصوره تخص احد مناجم الملح
اللي هي المتابعه ينضم اليها منك كيف
مراسله جزيره تامر صمادي ومن موسكو مراسل
الجزيره امين درهامي اهلا بكما
الاعين تتجه نحو سوليدار
جول ما قراناه منذ بدايه هذه النشره تتعلق
بالتصريحات من الجانب الروسي ابدا معك همم
تامر لمعرفه حقيقه الاوضاع في سوليدار
بناء على التصريحات الاكرانيه
لا محمد خلينا نكون واضحين حتى هذه اللحظه
لا يوجد بيان رسمي صادر عن الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه او هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
يرد على الحديث الروسي او الروايه الروسيه
المتعلقه بالسيطره على كامل المدينه
سيلدار باستثناء تصريح يتيم من صحه تعبير
لاحد مستشاري الرئيس الاوكراني خلال
الدقائق الاخيره الذي قال بان السيطره
المحتمله يقول السيطره المحتمله للقوات
الروسيه على سوليدار لن تحقق اين نتائج
حقيقيه على الارض باستثناء الدعايه همم
الروسيه في همم وسائل الاعلام الروسيه
التي تشير الى ذلك وتحاول ان تعطي لنفسها
يعني انتصارا وهميا على حد وصفي يقول بان
القوات الروسيه ضلت لاربعه اشهر متتاليه
تحاول السيطره على باخمود تحاول الى بخموت
المجاوره لسيلدار والاهم من الناحيه
الاستراتيجيه من سوليدار كما قال لكنها
اخفقت في ذلك ويقول بان السيطره المحتمله
على السوليدار سيكون حالها حال العديد من
القرى البلدات المدن التي تسيطر عليها
القوات الروسيه حتى هذه اللحظه في اكثر من
محور في اكثر من جبهه جنبا وشرقا اذا هذا
المستشار الذي كان يتحدث قبل قليل على
صفحته في التلجرام صفحته الرسميه هو يقلل
من الانتصار المحتمل للقوات الروسيه في
السليدار كما يقول ويصف ويصفه بالاتصال
الوهمي التصريحات الرسميه الصادره عن
الرئيس الاوكراني اخر تلك التصريحات خلال
الليله الماضيه تشير الى ان القوات
الاوكرانيه ما زالت تقاتل في سردار تقاتل
القوات الاوكرانيه تحدث عن وضع صعب في
دنياك وصفه الصعب واشار الى ان المرحله
الحاليه تتطلب ر مستوى المساعدات العسكريه
من قبل الحلفاء والشركاء وقال بان الحلفاء
والشركاء لديهم الامكانيه الكامله لتغيير
المعادله بشكل اكبر
وللحاق الهزيمه التي وصفها بالهزيمه
التاريخيه للقوات الروسيه على الارض وقال
بان انتصار اوكرانيا هو انتصار لاوروبا
وانتصار للولايات المتحده والغرب وان
الدفاع عن اوكرانيا هو دفاعا كامل الاراضي
الاوروبيه كما اشار كان هنالك ايضا طيله
خلال الماضيه تصريح اخر لنائبه وزير وزيره
الدفاع الاوكراني التي اشارت بان القتال
في سردار ما زال متواصلا وانه قتال عنيف
بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه
اميرنا درغامي ااا في مقابل هذه الروايه
الاوكرانيه غير رسميه غير الواضحه حتى هذه
اللحظه تم روايه قطعيه من طرف روسيا فيما
يتعلق بالاوضاع في سوريا دار واللافت انها
جاءت على لسان مالكي شركه باكنه
نعم محمد ليس فقط
رئيس دنيا لروسيا دينيس بوشينن الذي اكد
قبل قليل على ان القوات الروسيه سيطرت
بشكل كامل على مدينه سوليدار بل ذهب الى
ابعد من ذلك بوشينن حينما اعتبر السيطره
على سوليدار بانها ستفتح الطريق امام
القوات الروسيه همم من اجل اكمال السيطره
على الاراضي الخاضعه للموالي لروسيا او
التي يحسبونها ويعتبرونها اراضيهم
التاريخيه واعتبر ان ما حدث يعد يعني
انتقال من مرحله الى مرحله عندما تحدث عن
ان القوات الروسيه بسيطرتها على سوليدار
همم لاحقا على باخموت وعلى مدينه سيفرت
ستكون بالتالي قد دمرت بشكل كامل
الجبهه على طول منطقه جمباز وهنا الحديث
عن تحول عسكري استراتيجي فقط ل- اا
الاشاره السيطره على سوليدار بحسب طبعا
الروايه الروسيه يعد اول همم بين قوسين
نصر عسكري ميداني روسي همم من نوعه منذ
السيطره على مدينه سفر دانيت والاستشانك
همم في يوليو الماضي منذ ذلك الحين محمد
روسيا لم تحقق اي نصره عسكري اي تقدم
بالسيطره على مدينه من حجم سوليدار او
تقدم همم في مدينه من حجم بخمه همم
المجاوره اذا من شبه المؤكد كما طبعا
سمعنا اليوم على لسان برجوجن همم القوات
الروسيه وخصوصا وتحديدا قوات فاجنر سيطره
على وسط مدينه سوليدار قطع طرق الامداد عن
هذه المدينه وحاصرت كما قال عددا كبيرا من
الوحدات العسكريه اوكرانيا وكانت مصادر
عسكريه روسيه قد تحدثت الليله الماضيه على
ان قوه فاجنر اعطت مهله للقوات الاوكرانيه
المحاصره في سوليدار حتى منتصف الليله
الماضيه من اجل الاستسلام لكن تلك المصادر
عادت لتتحدث صباح اليوم على انه لم يستجب
او لم تستجب القوات الاوكرانيه لتلك همم
وبالتالي تواصلت بعض المعارك داخل ووسط
مدينه سوليدار فيما قالت قوه فاجنر انها
عمليات تمشيط من اجل اكمال السيطره بشكل
كامل وبمئه بالمئه على مدينه سوليدار شكرا
لك امين درغامي مراسل الجزيره كنت همم
معنا من موسكو اشكرك تامر رسماتي والراس
الجزيره كنت معنا من كيف